some interesting food for thought to
there and let's discuss some of these
points now with financial expert Marcus
hen who joins us in the studio today
good to have you with us you were just
listening to Professor sin and his
proposals which you make of it would
that work I think there are big
uncertainties if it would work in the
way he thinks of course in financial
crisis it's a classic measure to
devaluate your currency to be better off
however there's always the question how
much will you be harmed by the increase
of the imports how much will be harmed
by the change of the currency and it's
much more uncertain than mr. thermistors
in sess how exactly it will turn out for
Greece we think well we don't have a
crystal ball of course but what we do
know is what happened or what didn't
happen over the past five years of
bailout so far Greece is still in the
doldrums the people still suffer under
austerity measures how much longer can
this go on for and at any cost I think
there's an agreement with mr. sin-debt
this cannot go like this but the problem
is that austerity policy was the mistake
to say you should privatize valuable
asset to say that you have to decrease
your wages which then harms the economy
because they don't have any in demand
all these things have been the big
mistakes and even the former governments
have complained about the role of the
troika that they imposed totally
unreasonable cuts to the Greek economy
in a Greek state and I think this was
the mistake and we should have not done
this now we are there and we have to
change this so the finance minister
greek Finance Minister Yanis varoufakis
was right when he told the former prime
minister of Greece five years ago not to
accept the bailout so maybe they should
go this way now which they tried to do
and failed so far with their creditors
but they actually right that's what you
say of course a default should be always
taken as always possible because if you
prolong this situation it will not
change anything will be just worse for
both sides for the craters and the data
so that's a problem and you have to be
as always possible with the good debt
work out but we have no international
mechanism for that that's the problem
there is no framework to do this and
that's why it took so long what Greece
needs money it gets money from the
international creditors but it also says
that it will do
a bit more in order to procure money at
home namely taxing its elite how
realistic is that because it hasn't
happened in the past that's true it's a
real task however too serious at least
has the advantage that they are not as
deeply involved in the former problems
as other party so I think there's a
chance now with syriza and I think they
will take it but of course they have the
same problems people will take all the
money out of Greece they were just evade
Texas I think that's let's not sure yet
what they will achieve but I think they
have a better chance than the other
parties